en el vídeo pasado definimos la noción
de un determinante de una matriz de 2 x
2 entonces digamos que tenemos una
matriz b que es de la forma a b
d
ok donde estos en realidad son cualquier
número y definimos en el vídeo pasado el
determinante de una matriz de este tipo
a lo cual denota mos con estos símbolos
y que también se puede escribir como dos
barritas por acá y la matriz aquí
adentro
ok puede ser la letra con la cual
denotamos a la matriz o puede ser tal
cual los valores de la matriz o sea
puesto aquí a b c d y todas estas cosas
denotan la misma cosa que es el
determinante de esta matriz ok es muy
importante no confundirse entre una
matriz y un determinante de una matriz
ok si tiene estas rayas largas esto
significa que estamos hablando de un
determinante que en realidad termina
siendo un solo número a diferencia de
las matrices que son cuatro números
distintos acomodados en esta forma que
tienen estos paréntesis ok paréntesis
significa matriz raya significa
determinante bueno el chiste es que
definimos que el determinante de una
matriz era tal cual este por éste o sea
- este por este deporte ok
tomamos esta diagonal y multiplicamos
estos números y le resta vamos lo que
nos quedaba de multiplicar esta diagonal
y encontramos que esta cosa el
determinante de b era muy importante
para determinar algunas cosas sobre la
matriz ve en el vídeo pasado encontramos
la fórmula para sacar la matriz inversa
de una matriz b de una matriz de 2 por 2
y esta fórmula lo que decía es que la
matriz inversa es igual a 1 entre ab -
bc por una matriz por acá que en
realidad lo que hacía era nada más tomar
estas dos entradas y cambiarlas del
hogar y a estas dos entradas multiplicar
las x menos 1 de este lado de esta
matriz nos quedaría a ver el a nos lo
mandan hasta acá o se la queda por acá
el d nos lo mandan por acá y nos queda
menos
y menos si bueno pero ahora si vamos al
meollo del asunto el chiste es que esta
matriz inversa no está definida para
todas las matrices b lo cual tiene todo
el sentido del mundo porque no todas las
matrices de dos por dos son invertibles
y resulta que esta matriz está definida
sí solo si esta cosa de acá es distinta
de cero ok y si ésta es distinta de cero
esta matriz resulta ser invertible y su
inversa es ésta pero si esta cosa de acá
resulta ser igual a cero la matriz
inversa no está bien definida porque no
se puede dividir entre cero y la matriz
b resulta no ser invertible ok entonces
a de menos b se determina si la matriz b
es invertible o no b es invertible
y sólo si hay menos veces es distinto de
cero ok pero a veces es igual al
determinante de b o sea justo en el
vídeo pasado nos dimos cuenta que esta
cantidad era súper importante y
decidimos nombrar la determinante de b
porque determina si ves invertible o no
pero lo importante con lo que nos
quedamos en el vídeo pasado es con esta
definición de que a de menos veces es el
determinante de b y siempre en nájera
lineal estamos tratando de generalizar
todas las cosas que suceden por ejemplo
en matrices de 2 x 2
matrices de n por n donde n es cualquier
número o sea 50 x 50 matrices de 100 por
ciento pero pues vamos pasito a pasito
entonces vamos a empezar por definir una
matriz de tres por tres nuestra matriz a
es una matriz de tres por tres
a las entradas de las matrices cuando
son matrices más grandes nos gusta
llamarlos de cierta forma que nada más
con saber su nombre sepamos exactamente
cuál es su posición dentro de la matriz
gay porque si no pues tendremos que usar
muchísimas letras imagínense una matriz
de cien por cien el abecedario entero no
nos alcanza entonces lo que hacemos es
usar subíndices por ejemplo a esta
entrada de aquí le vamos a llamar a uno
uno a uno de que está en la primera fila
y uno de que está en la primera columna
aunque entonces aquí este va a ser el a
12 porque está en la primera fila y en
la segunda columna gay a 13
y aquí este va a ser el a 21 a 22 a 23
a 31 está en la tercera fila y en la
primera columna a 32
33 es una buena forma de llamarle a los
elementos de una matriz no entonces esta
es una matriz de tres por tres porque
tiene tres filas y tres columnas que hay
matriz de tres por tres
y lo que vamos a hacer ahora es definir
el determinante para matrices de 3 por 3
que vamos a definir muy importante eso
que lo estamos definiendo justo en este
momento entonces el determinante de a de
una matriz de 3 por 3 lo vamos a definir
como a 11 a 11 por el determinante de la
matriz de 2 por 2 que nos quede de
eliminar las filas y las columnas que
contengan 11 aunque entonces tomamos
este a 11 lo ponemos aquí y luego
eliminamos la columna y la fila que
contienen a 11 y sacamos el determinante
de las entradas que nos queden ok de
esta sub matriz que algunas personas le
llaman el menor de a 11 pero por el
momento vamos a seguirle llamando sub
matriz
y tenemos que sacar el determinante de
la sub matriz que tiene a
22 a 23 a 32 y 33 gay que es el
determinante de esta matriz que nos
queda de eliminar la fila y la columna
que contienen a 11 que es la entrada por
la que estamos multiplicando ok aquí
tenemos un más que es súper súper
importante porque porque ahorita lo que
viene es un menos que siempre vamos a ir
más menos más y si estuviéramos haciendo
a los determinantes de matriz de cuatro
por cuatro aquí iría otro menos pero
pues ese lo vamos a ver en otro vídeo
próximamente el chiste es que ahorita
nos toca un menos y vamos a tomar esta
entrada que es la a-12 y la vamos a
multiplicar por el determinante de
alberdi ghana y cual determinante bien
pues el determinante de la sub matriz
que nos queda de eliminar la fila
la columna de 12 que tenemos que sacar
el terminante de 21 a 23 a 31 y a 33
y finalmente vamos a sumarle porque ya
sumamos y restamos y entonces ahora toca
sumar otra vez a 13 a 13 por el
determinante de lo que nos quede de
quitar esta columna y esta fila o sea a
21 a 22 a 31 y a 32
ok entonces todo esto es el determinante
de a para cualquier matriz de tres por
tres que es muy importante que nosotros
lo estamos definiendo así y aunque no
sea tan intuitivo así pues la verdad es
que la idea de fondo es exactamente la
misma que cuando definimos este
determinante como a de menos bs porque
hay tal vez no lo voy a demostrar pero
con este determinante que acabamos de
definir podemos determinar si una matriz
de tres por tres es invertible o no o
sea si tenemos una matriz y le sacamos
su determinante y ese determinante es
distinto de cero eso ya nos asegura que
éste
matrix es invertible y de la misma forma
si sacamos el determinante de la matriz
de esta forma este tipo determinante que
acabamos de definir y resulta ser igual
a 0 eso nos asegura que esta matriz no
es invertible pero bueno aquí se ven un
montón de letras y tal vez no queda
claro bien qué es lo que estoy haciendo
por lo cual pues vamos a hacer un
ejemplo
tomemos una matriz
que sea igual a 12 421
y 431
entonces si yo quiero sacar el
determinante de esta matriz
lo que tengo que hacer es tomar esta
entrada el 1 y multiplicarlo por el
determinante de la sub matriz que nos
queda de eliminar la fila en la que éste
se encuentra y luego quitar la columna
en la que ésta se encuentra y sacarle el
determinante a la sub matriz que nos
queda aunque repito algunas personas
este determinante de acá le llaman la
menor de esta entrada o sea la menor de
esta posición de esta entrada pero
nosotros podemos seguirle llamando sub
matriz que entonces lo que vamos a sacar
es este determinante y multiplicarlo por
uno ok entonces tenemos que sacar el
determinante de menos 13
1 y después como aquí ya sumamos nos
toca a restar entonces nosotros vamos a
restar 2
por el determinante de lo que nos que
debe quitar la columna en la que se
encuentra el 2 y la fila en la que se
encuentra el 2 entonces tenemos aquí
otra matriz
esta matriz y vamos a sacarle su
determinante y multiplicarlo por 2 bueno
x menos 2 muy importante sobre el menos
entonces aquí va 2 3 4 y 1 y finalmente
como aquí sumamos restamos sumemos más
44 por el determinante
2 - 14 02 menos 140 que y entonces pues
tenemos que hacer todas estas cuentas
aquí lo que tenemos es 1 por este
determinante que es y se acuerdan por
aquí lo tenemos a de menos bs
así es que tenemos menos uno por uno
menos uno por uno y después tenemos que
restar este por este tres por cero
de una vez podemos ir haciendo las
cuentas entonces menos uno por uno es
menos uno y aquí menos tres por cero es
menos cero o sea que todo esto nos queda
menos uno y después queremos restar dos
x
2 x 1 2 x 1 - 3 x 4 3 x 4 y finalmente
queremos sumar 4 por 2 por 0 2 por 0 -
menos 1 por cuatro menos 1 x
esto de aquí es este determinante esto
de aquí es este determinante y pues ya
habíamos visto que estoy acá es este
determinante pero de aquí nos quedan dos
por 12 menos 3 por 4 3 por 4 es 12 o sea
2 - 12 eso es menos
y aquí tenemos dos por cero eso es un
cero y aquí tenemos menos menos uno por
cuatro y eso es simplemente un 4 ahora
muy importante que no se nos olvide
multiplicar por estos numeritos de aquí
y bueno esto es igual a 1 pero menos 1 -
1 - 2 x menos 10 más 20 y finalmente 4x4
más 16 entonces 20 más 16 menos uno eso
es simplemente 35 todo es igual el
determinante de ese determinante de c es
35 y como 35 es distinto de 0 es todo lo
que nos dice es que se es una matriz
invertible está padre no bueno en el
próximo vídeo vamos a hacer lo mismo
pero para matrices de n por n n por m
donde n puede ser cualquier número que
puede ser 100 puede ser 1000 puede ser
un millón el número que se te ocurra
vamos a encontrar una fórmula para sacar
su determinante